This course is about really challenging computer problems,
and the area of computer science that deals with these challenging problems
is called theoretical computer science, or more specifically, complexity theory.
In complexity theory, we ask the question of how hard
certain problems are to solve for a computer.
So how much time you really need to solve that problem.
And at the end of this course, we'll even talk about deceptively simple problems
that are impossible to solve for computers, and that area is called computability.
I will assume that you know some basics about algorithms, programming, and mathematics.
After taking this course, you will have an understanding
of how to recognize, and actually, also solve, very challenging problems.
Plus, theoretical computer science is a very rich and active field of research
and this course will prepare you to dig deeper
once you are infected by the fascinations of this field.